[Music]
the evil within - was announced at this
year's e3 with a wonderfully weird
trailer and to my surprise I find myself
pretty excited it's surprising because I
actually didn't like the evil within all
that much but I do believe a lot of the
game's imagery and ideas has the
potential to make a truly great horror
game which is why I'm glad developer
tango GameWorks is getting a second
chance with the sequel coming in only a
few months now's the perfect time to
take a look at where the original fell
short and my hopes for the evil within -
but let's quickly get something out of
the way the evil within most obvious
problem and the one that got the most
attention during its launch was those
pesky black bars it was an attempt to
give the game a cinematic look by
replicating movie aspect ratios lots of
people didn't care for this with
fan-made fixes popping up and eventually
the devs patched in the ability to
disable it in fact based on the footage
we've seen from the evil within - they
seem to have abandoned the black bars
altogether so don't really have to worry
about that okay got that out of the way
now when it comes to horror action games
the balance between these two genres has
always been delicate in the case of the
evil within the to feel at odds with
each other the tense atmosphere built up
in the game's opening hospital scene is
deflated by the blockbuster style city
destroying cutscene five minutes later
and the games more hectic combat
sequences feels hampered by the games of
very limited ammo and claustrophobic
camera there are moments where the
horror and action are blended well like
this early sequence in a village but a
lot of times the game swings wildly
between the two I would love to see the
evil within to strike a far more
consistent balance with its horror and
action another in ballast evil within
has comes from these styles of gameplay
it uses there are primarily three types
of situations unkillable enemies that
you must hide or run from areas where
you must either stealth or shoot through
and waves of enemies you have to fight
and none of these feel as good to play
as a game that just does one of these
really
well the AI you were hiding from seems
like they are moving on a pre-arranged
track and feels more like you're
avoiding a scripted animatronic robot
than an intelligent monster the stealth
gets the job done but it's pretty
simplistic hide throw a bottle stab and
repeat and once you get caught you have
no choice but to engage in combat which
means if you're low on bullets better to
just die in reload and the shooting
itself is fine in sections with solo
enemies but starts to feel clunky and
too imprecise when dealing with a large
horde and the limited ammo can make
these moments feel very unforgiving in a
controller throwing kind of way rather
than a creepy tense kind of way like
it's supposed to I want to see evil
within to improve all of this make the
AI more threatening and clever when
hiding improve the stealth by giving
more options to run away and hide and if
you're gonna make me fight mandatory
large hordes give me better controls and
just a little bit more ammo
all these gameplay styles also feel
isolated from one another and are
separated into very identifiable video
game sections you enter a new room where
the game is basically saying hey it's
time to shoot these guys and then you
went to another room where it says and I
got to run away from this guy because he
can't be killed why well that's just
what's happening in this room it's less
about player choice on how to solve the
situation and rather figuring out
exactly what the developer wants you to
do and doing it which is why I'm really
excited about what even within two is
calling these new less linear areas you
get an open space to explore and find
supplies while avoiding or dealing with
enemies we haven't seen this in action
but it sounds like it has the potential
to take these elements of hiding stealth
and combat and letting the player decide
which of these is the best course of
action
[Applause]
and finally there's the story the first
game story is hot garbage the characters
are never giving any meaningful traits
or motivations there is no understanding
of what is happening in the plot and
what your goal is for the vast majority
of the game like really you just walk
from one scary set piece to the next
with little undercurrent of theme
zombies a village hospital scary armed
lady it's all well-made sleepy stuff and
I give them credit for not resorting to
jump scares but nothing really ties it
together in any meaningful way
it's just horror things
[Music]
thankfully evil within two's premise
already seems to be on the path towards
addressing this yes detective Sebastian
Castellanos returns as the main
character but he was such a non
personality that they have a chance to
really start over with him
the premise is about his dead daughter a
minor thread that was touched upon in
the original game turns out she's not
dead and he has to delve back into the
twisted nightmare world to save her
already we have a clear motive for the
character and the player that has good
potential for personal investment in the
story there also appears to be more of a
theme in the horror and scares
themselves the trailer and promotional
imagery of the game focuses on this
white substance and camera lenses how
this relates to Sebastian's daughter
remains to be seen but it's already more
interesting than the original evil with
ins general theme of horror I'm reminded
of Silent Hill 2 and how one of the
reasons its horror is so memorable is
because it's all directly tied into the
trauma of protagonist James and his wife
everything from the enemy designed to
side characters all tied back to that
relationship if evil within to can use
its imagery to the same effect with
Sebastian and his daughter they can
create some genuinely haunting horror I
do have one very specific request though
please keep Claire de Lune it was the
best part of the first game
[Music]
the original evil within is a great idea
of a game with a talented group of
developers behind it but it suffered
from a lack of focus and original
identity opting to try and be all the
horror games at once
the evil within - is a chance to give
the series its own unique mark if they
can improve and expand on the stealth
aspects tone down some of the combat
sequences and have the story really take
advantage of the personal investment
between Sebastian and his daughter I
will be pretty happy I hope they can
pull it off and we won't have long to
wait because the evil within - comes out
on October 13th which means we are sure
to have more coverage soon so subscribe
to GameSpot so you don't miss anything
seriously though like key Kirkland
[Music]
you